you talk a lot about your mom you've
already spoken about her yeah
um what was your favorite jokes about
your mom
because you you've gotten a lot of
mileage out of your mom over the years
yeah
she's you know my mom she was such a
funny person but didn't know it you know
people like that where you go you're so
funny
how can i use this to my advantage and
uh
she'd walk into a restaurant first words
out of her mouth
could we get some extra butter and the
waiter would say well let us seat your
party first man
butter she liked her butter yeah she
loved her butter
a lot of babies when they're born
they're powdered i was buttered
i was slippery but a lot of fun
you know my mom though she just was a
she was a lovely person you would have
loved it and you know she
got to see a lot of my stand-up and you
know
i talk about my dad she'd rub her arms
and
she would have been great in the
pandemic i would have loved
my mom in the pandemic just hang out
with her
well first of all she'd be so thrilled
my hands were this clean
yeah my hands you know because she was
the kind of person
if your hands were dirty she would come
to where you're sitting
bring a bowl of soapy water in a cloth
and wash her
she was our own mother teresa yeah but
it sounds like she was into this
she was into people washing their hands
long before the pandemic she was she was
ahead of her time what can i say
and they imagine the food we'd have yeah
i
i mean you'd always you're hungry we
just
ate well you look a little hungry you
know my mom that's the reason i i'm
you know we traced her uh ancestry back
to the mayflower and that's why i have
such a bread problem
okay right i don't know i just like that
i know
it's funny don't you have jokes that you
like that never work
yes have you not seen me perform
literally
yes but i have a lot of jokes i do that
i'm
that i like that maybe the crowd doesn't
like
but if it makes who cares but it makes
me laugh it's like a gift to myself
yes like every time i'm in california
i'm performing i go i just was in
a thousand oaks but i only counted
around 900 of them
never get never but i do it
i am committed to that joke i will do it
over
and over and over i'm curious about
something what was your mom
reaction to your standup did she she
must been very proud of you which did
she like that you did
did stand up she hate she didn't well
she would be sad when i do stuff about
my dad because she missed them
but when i would do her she'd go louie
you've got a cute act thank you mother
that's the last thing a comic wants to
hear
a key it's cute yeah yeah
you're pretty good no um and uh
she said but you're doing me all wrong
i go what do you mean i don't do that i
do more of
this i go what is that well that's just
my thing
and i go uh i just love you mom because
you're so insane
and you're just uh you know she just was
so funny
like and she was she didn't she have any
idea she was funny
yeah you know if the car door slammed
she was a window monitor you know what
that is don't you no
car door slam she's right over there oh
the johnsons are home
[Laughter]
my oldest kid's on a drugs i think
and my dad would get so mad he go oh
look at your mother you know the fbi
don't
they don't even question people anymore
they just call your mother
and my mom would be oh
she had the best hmm just
always a bad story with your mom when my
with my mom when i'd show up
how are you mom well
i'm okay what
do you hear about shirley you're not
even sure who shirley is really
she fell then she'd look at me like i
had something to do with it